[Music]
so I'm Adam I'm Chris and this is
Android suspenders today we're going to
talk a little bit about Kotlin
co-routines but to get started a little
bit of background many of you are
probably familiar with those already is
the idea of androids main thread and
just like almost every other UI toolkit
out there androids exposes a single UI
or main thread for doing updates to
parts of your UI so some of the things
that you might find yourself doing on
the main thread inflating views you
could be doing measure and layout
operations to change the shape of your
view hierarchy you could be drawing or
many other things really like processing
input events and so on and so forth so
today you're probably familiar with this
16 millisecond time limit the vast
majority of devices out there have a
refresh rate of 60 Hertz which means
that you have just over 16 milliseconds
to do all the work necessary in order to
deliver a smooth frame rate so what
happens when that display rate goes up
so 90 Hertz means you have 12
milliseconds 120 Hertz means you have 8
milliseconds and you have less and less
time to get some of this work done if
you take a look at assist trace you'll
usually find that the things that caused
you to miss a frame and thereby have
kind of jank in your application is
really app code like if you're binding
items to a recycler view reading from a
data store or so on and so forth these
are all bits of work that it would be
really great if we could keep this off
of that main thread and out of this
critical path so how do we fix it well
this talk isn't about achieving eight
millisecond refresh boundaries this is
about making use of the resources we
have available and all the phones that
we have have multiple cores in them
today so how do we actually make use of
that well some of you probably remember
this thing it's been around for quite
some time and has a lot of issues it's
all composes a little bit badly has some
issues around rotation it's really easy
to get wrong
there's executors which most Java
developers are familiar with and this
kind of lets you share some thread pools
which is nice but it's otherwise kind of
a really raw API you can build things
out of it but it's not really convenient
to use on its own loaders loaders
sort of thing that we're certainly out
there that solved a few problems but it
was pretty narrowly scoped it's really
now deprecated so there's not a whole
lot there we can use futures
there's listenable future which has
started showing up in more Android XA P
is but you may not want to pull in all
of guava and all of the infrastructure
that really helps you leverage some of
the things that you can do with it and
unless you're working on min SDK 24 you
can't use completable future either and
really there's a whole bunch of other
reasons why you might not want to use
that to begin with so there are a lot of
other libraries out there I mentioned
guava guava is certainly one that you
can pull into your app rx Java is super
popular it's a great library does a lot
of things as well but if you're sitting
here in this talk today you're probably
here to talk about co-routines which is
a new feature that went fully stable in
Kotlin 1.3 just this fall so why should
we use them great so when I think about
this question I'm thinking about what
does your typical mobile app do and I
think for the most part you can describe
them as kind of crude apps and I don't
mean the American Slang I mean the fact
that they create they read they update
and they delete data usually to some
kind of local data source like a
database or whatever it be and then go
to it further a lot of apps will also
have some kind of sync so they upload
data and pull data back from some kind
of web service now apps are actually
pretty simple computationally you're not
retexe in the CPU that much really yes
the logic can be quite tricky to get
right but actually they're pretty simple
and of course Android we put a lot of
stuff in your way like we make out your
live harder but in actually your apps
are actually pretty simple from a logic
point of view so WIPO routines well how
do they actually fix that well I think
they're great for i/o tasks especially
for a resource constraint system like
the phones and tablets you're using
today
now you can't create a thread for every
Network request you ever use because
Fred's taking the space of about a
megabyte to 2 megabytes of RAM every
time you create one that's why Fred
pools and actually cache Fred's for you
now carotenes on the other hand taking
the sort of realm of tens of kilobytes
in turns out read carotene they use
Fred's underneath but they use them a
much more optimal way
also there in my mind anyway they have
an easier development model it's a lot
easier for developers to kind of come
into a new source source source and see
an imperative line-by-line
cocoa routine over something like an Rx
Java chain like to have to understand
what's happening there as a in my mod
anyway easier and same thing for
callbacks like everyone knows what
callback hell and I'm to go line by line
and say see where you've been called and
stuff and so co-routines help hopefully
anyway fix that so a lot of this talk
was written in mind with an app a sample
app that I've been writing for the past
twelve months or so good TV it was
originally I went all-in on Eric's job
it was Eric's Java from top to bottom
and I've kind of slowly brought curtains
into it it's now about 50% carotenes 50%
Eric's Java so he still uses both and I
think they both have a place in Android
development and so yeah go views both
now as Android developers we have to
care about apk size and Method counts
now in Kotlin in my off anyway I'm using
free libraries from the Kotlin Curtin's
kind of tree the core which contains the
majority of what you'll actually use
Android which had support for the
Android main thread amongst other small
things and then arcs to which allows you
to interact with arcs Java so if you're
not using Irish Java you won't need that
one it's pretty small anyway now if you
actually pull down
there's jar file store from maven
central or wherever they would come to
about 700 centi four kilobytes so that's
quite big and it should be a you know
alarm bells are ringin but once you
actually put that in your apk it
actually shrinks down six-pack ting and
it comes down to about 500 kilobytes but
that method references are still quite
high that's like 5 percent if you're 64
K as soon as you turn on minify and now
this is just tree shaking so that no
optimization turned on here or ProGuard
they both have similar results you're
looking about a hundred and twelve
thirteen k so a lot less and again the
method references has dropped but as
soon as you turn on optimization and
then you go for all of trying to fix all
the ProGuard rules you're coming down to
that magic valley which is less than
hundred kilobytes and again you're met
with references now 854 like it's less
than 1% 1% of your reference
now one thing to note when you're is in
ProGuard or r8 is that you need to use
this rule it's not currently bundled
with the jars but hopefully it'll be
added soon but it's a pretty simple rule
to add so hopefully by now you're
thinking about how you might use
co-routines in your app so let's go
ahead and talk a little bit about
actually writing them so anything that
you can do with a one shot callback or
future you can do with a suspend
function everything with co-routines is
kind of based around this idea of
suspending function as a basis for
creating api's suspend functions can
stop and yield their thread without
blocking and they can be resumed later
like a callback and they can only be
called from another suspend function so
just to set up all the machinery
involved in that but the core thing is
is that all of this kind of fits on one
slide there's less to remember the rest
of the language still works the same in
the presence of suspend functions and
we'll spend the rest of the talk talking
about that so here's a suspending method
from chris's app actually this is a data
repository for TV shows so you go ahead
and you call this update show function
with an ID we get some shows and we get
a little bit more data from a remote
source and a little bit more data from a
second source
finally we merge all that together and
we save that data so these three main
tasks where we spend the bulk of the
time these are done sequentially but
none of these tasks have a dependency on
one another so wouldn't it be nice if we
could do this concurrently so with the
async builder we can do this so we're
gonna start from the very top here we
start by opening a co-routine scope and
this is important because this allows us
to perform this parallel decomposition
using the async builder it brings a cur
routine scope receiver into scope for
this lambda block that we have so first
we build the async operation and the
second and the third and then we await
the result of each one in turn so the
nice thing is here is that we've
launched all of these things let them
run kind of independently and then we
bring them back together again so since
all of these things can be now done in
parallel things should complete faster
so trying to do this with raw threads by
hand would be a lot more code which
need to maintain along the way so the
async builder is for when we want to run
something and then later await the
result after kind of giving it a chance
to finish while we're doing something
else it's very similar to C sharp or
promises in JavaScript so what about
when you just want to launch something
and forget about it though well there's
something for that too it's just called
launch it works pretty much the same way
so in this case it's is a lot more
similar to executors and just sort of
submitting a task submitting something
to an Android handler for example when
we just want to fire and forget and deal
with it later so that's a little bit
about the basics of running co-routines
in isolation how do you run them on
Android though so in this case you might
have an arch components of you model and
wouldn't it be nice if we had kind of an
easy way to put all this stuff together
automatically we needed to be able to
open a scope so where do you get one of
those things to begin with that you can
launch things into well in this case our
view model has a show repository which
is our data layer and we have a view
state that the viewer activity or
fragment can observe we can refresh on
construction and when we actually go to
refresh we launch into this new view
model scope extension property this is
coming very soon to the Android X
libraries those of you who like to watch
commits in a OSP might have seen this
going already
so the Refresh function launches a car
routine uses the launch builder which
then calls the update function on the
repository and our co-routine resumes
back on the main thread after update
show returns so we can safely manipulate
our view hierarchy with the results just
on the next line of code we have this
nice clean sequential ordering of
operations so those of you who want to
go check out this thing that's upcoming
you can go to this link take a look at
the change so far in advance of the
actual release this is coming in an
upcoming release of our KTX libraries so
let's go ahead and demystify how some of
this works a little bit but before we
can go to too deep we need to start
talking about some of the other
primitives that are work under the hood
here ok great so we're gonna talk about
jobs a little bit so what is it job so
here when you actually look at this code
snippet when we just look out from Adam
you're actually using the launch method
now when you actually run that launch
method it returns what we call a job now
job is allows us to reference keep a
reference
I'm going piece of work and it has
really one method on it and it's called
cancel now obviously in this example we
wouldn't just call cancel straightaway
after we've launched something that
would be ridiculous but what it does
allow us to do is handle something like
double refreshes like if you have
something like forward pull to refresh
in your app and an automated refresh you
don't look both stuff in at the same
time and then you have two things happen
at the same time so here this code
snippet you can keep a reference to the
one that's currently running and if it
happens again like a refresh is called
and you can cancel the first one and so
that's the kind of app job kind of works
it's a very simple object but it allows
you to keep a reference of the ongoing
piece of work so you may have seen that
viewmodel scope thing and wondered what
is Adam explained it earlier and you can
have a scope and it provides you with
all the context you need to run so a
launch or an async so take a look at how
they actually work underneath so
co-routine scope is an interface that
allows objects to provide a scope for
carotenes think things like things with
a lifecycle so fragments activities view
model even and they can revise a
lifecycle for the curtain itself and
start and stop it as it needs a sink and
launch used to be sort of global methods
and now a recent refactor brought them
as instant methods on the carotene scope
what it means is then mentally anyway is
that instead of just launching something
you're launching a carotene on X so I'm
launching a curry teen on the activity
it just changed it mentally in your head
in that it's tied to the life cycle of
something else right if you're used to
working with the lifecycle owner in arch
components so far you know the lifecycle
owner has a lifecycle that you can then
observe and attach things to similarly a
co-routine scope has a co-routine
context that carries along everything
necessary to know how to launch
co-routine some of the stuff we're gonna
talk about a bit
and similarly correcting scopes provide
a default context so you can provide a
default context for all the curtains
that are overrun on it so I think things
like what kind of fred paul dispatcher
it runs on the job the parent jobs that
will actually to cancel it later and
other things which you can add to it
it's basically a map the context
and it's good that's a good day for
slide back okay cool so let's take a
look at another example this time we're
not going to use view model scope the
automated thing we've added to Android X
we're going to write out ourselves so
here you can see that we create a job
and now it's just a simple instantiation
we're just gonna keep a reference to it
and then we're going to keep that
contact create a carotene scope using a
job and that means that anything that
runs on it allows us to track back using
that job object we're also going to give
it a default dispatcher we're gonna talk
more about that later but basically it
means is that anything that is launched
on that scope or we automatically run on
the main thread Android Manfred in this
isn't so once we've done that we have a
refresh method again and this time
instead of that view model scope the
automated thing we're going to use our
own created scope and again saki-san
code just using a different type of
scope this time but this time the
launched we scoped
to the odd-job object we created earlier
which means that anon and cleared which
is the callback we have in view model to
actually not when it's been torn down we
can actually just called job got
canceled and that means that any pair of
teens which are currently running when
the view model goes down will be
canceled at the same time reduces memory
leaks or you know whatever it is just
allows it to tidy up
so if you actually have a look at how
things are run now
so we've launched our routine and now
we're going to go into our update show
method so here we are in our carotene so
I'll launch which is modeled by that
blue thing going around now here in the
object show method which is denoted by
the yellow arrow so we're gonna go past
that first piece of code which is the
async builder at this point we have a
first curry team running which is
everything and that's doing the local
show store stuff so it's running nicely
and it's doing its thing now the outer
curtain is going to go past that and go
past the second async which the remote
here again we've got so we now have two
curry teams running and they're both off
we have free currencies but two inner
ones to child proteins so once they're
launched in their rune and going along
we afford on to the first weight
now this point were waiting for that
first async the local to actually finish
itself up and then not return a result
which is what a weight will return but
at this point
because we're waiting on that first
async the outer coating is what we call
suspended
it's just sat there doing nothing but
during that time that view model has
been torn down is the activities gone
away or whatever it would be and we've
called job lat cancel now at this point
the outer carotene is canceled and then
the inner two are also canceled and now
that's similar carotene scope gives us
and scoping in general gives us for free
and that childcare routines
automatically inherit from its parent
carotene so if the parent coatings have
been cancelled anything below it will
also be that some of the nice stuff has
been added recently but what if you're
not actually using P models you know a
lot of us might not be using it and that
we have over api's we just later do
similar other things so it's part of the
Android architecture components we added
a listener at least the functionality
for life cycles so here's a very quick
example of how you use them generally
and you create a lifecycle observer and
this in this example we're using default
and when you create and it has methods
for each of the different lifecycle
events so on create destroyed stop start
whatever it be and to actually use it on
like an activity or whatever it be you
create an instance and you add observer
hopefully you've seen yourself before so
this build kind of scope aware lifecycle
observer which allows us to scope
carotenes to the an actual lifecycle
instance the primary API we'll use here
is that we'll pass another lambda and
that's the thing that we've run once
we've say been started I mean she's kind
of what you want usually mister time so
well now look at its implementation so
the first thing we want to do is on
start so that's when we'll start running
our piece of code and say well create a
co-routine scope using that job and then
we're going to run it on the dispatch
it's not main you can choose what that
be and then we'll call skip that launch
and then just call our lambda pretty
simple really and then finally a non
stop which seems like a good life cycle
to use that will call in that keys go
but we'll eventually cancel the job and
that will means that co-routine if it's
still during that point will be canceled
so if you can see that code isn't
actually that complex it's like okay
with Ethan at 100x so it's not nice to
use but in actually you look at the sort
of deep down of it it's actually pretty
simple and then to actually finish it
all off will provide a nice build
function and you pass it a lambda and it
will automatically add it for you
and what it allows us to do is stuff
like this so we're here we have a
details fragment and um decorated we
will use our live scope accent
revolution and then just run something
and that will automatically started when
we get to it'll be started when we go at
start and the new fragment and they'll
be closed or ended when we get on on
stop brings it on to cancellation right
we've talked a lot about this idea of
cancelling a KO routine but what
actually happens when this thing cancels
I mean if you just have kind of a block
of code that's running what gets torn
down what do you need to do to sort of
clean up so when a KO routine is
cancelled if it's cancelled while it's
suspended so it's waiting on something
else to happen in callback terms the
callback just hasn't been invoked yet
it'll throw a cancellation exception or
rather the curtain will resume from the
point that it was suspended with a
cancellation exception so what does that
actually look like here's our example
from before so what happens if we need
to clean something up if this is
canceled in the middle of that update
show function well because if there's a
cancellation exception this is something
that we kind of know how to do already a
plain old finally blocks run is expected
we didn't have to add any new concepts
beyond what we already know from the
rest of Kotlin but if blocking code is
running cancellation requires some
explicit cooperation in order to stop
what it's doing so we can check for that
cancellation explicitly in a couple of
ways generally this means checking to
see if your codeine is currently active
in one way shape or form and there are a
couple of useful patterns for doing this
so one of those patterns is that if you
know that your job is already cancelled
you can call any one of the stock
suspending methods such as yield use the
example here to force the cancellation
exception to be thrown relying on that
standards and implementation that I
mentioned before that if you're
cancelled when you're trying to suspend
then you'll resume with that
cancellation exception so we know that
this will immediately throw if we happen
to be cancelled but if you're in a tight
loop you can also just check this is
active that's available from any
suspending scope and you can just simply
stop what you're doing there's no reason
to really involve an exception here if
all you're doing is some sort of tight
inner computation
Loup that you need to break out of which
kind of leads nicely up into how
exceptions are handled with co-routines
in general and there are a few things
that are really worth pointing out
especially if you followed some of the
Kotlin exco routines development leading
up to release because there were some
really significant changes that happened
the first is that launch will wreath row
unhandled exceptions as they happen so
more precisely it fails the parent it
cancels its its parent job the parent
sees a cancellation exception with the
original exception as the cause in the
exception object itself so similar to a
thread they get dispatched to the
default exception handler at the root of
a job tree if nothing else manages to
handle that but your co routine context
also gets a chance to intercept you can
attach a special element to the cur team
context itself that you can use to
handle on handled exceptions so let's go
ahead and see how that works here's
again our example from before and say
that save show throws a very domain
specific exception in this case so in
this case this will be treated like an
uncaught exception at runtime just like
anything else that throws an uncaught
exception on your main thread so async
is a little bit different if an
exception is thrown well something that
you launch with async is running it'll
hold on to that exception and only throw
when the caller calls a wait so coming
back to our example from before again
let's go ahead and use what we know we
throw our exception from one of these
async jobs but that gets thrown from
this call to a weight itself so we know
exactly where we need to try and catch
that exception just kind of in the
normal way and handle that error but
there's a gotcha here and that's that
async works the same way as launched in
terms of how this nested job tree is
handled the deferred object that it
returns is just another kind of job and
so it'll cancel the parent if it fails
with an unhandled exception just like
launch does and it'll do this even if we
did it in a weight and called it now
this is kind of important because if
something throws an exception it's
really important that your app know
about it like it shouldn't just
disappear into the ether but at the same
time it kind of defeats the purpose of
the code in this sample here like we
caught it what are we supposed to do
here
well in this case instead of using
co-routines
at the top to open up this parallel
decomposition we can use supervisor
scope it works exactly like co-routine
scope except with a supervisor job which
is a special kind of job that won't be
canceled if a child fails with an
unhandled exception one more spot yep
it will only be thrown from this await
method here cool so earlier we mentioned
that we can actually decide where
co-routines have run and what kind of
fred they brought on because actually on
the JVM and on Android we actually still
run on Fred's he still uses fred paul
underneath so we still can decide where
that she gets dispatched on now let's
have a look so we here we have our
launch a very simple launch which is
missing a scope for you know just look
at example now default actually is that
the context will be using what we call a
dispatcher stop default that's a default
dispatcher that's kind of given for you
for free and it's supposed to be sort of
default for everything really
essentially a computation thread pool if
you're used to using that from our
Xstrata so what is a protein dispatcher
which is what it basically is what is
the thing which runs and schedules
curtains as I mentioned earlier it's
schedules or carotenes to run on
something on a Fred I know in our case
now this patch it's not default which is
the default which you get is that you
see CPU camp Fred so it has say your
device has four CPUs in it you will get
a Fred Paul at four which isn't so great
for things IO so most apps will be doing
a lot on network or disk or whatever it
be so it's not so great for that and so
yeah it's mostly more like a
computational type dispatcher but it's
also an elastic Fred executor which
we'll talk about in a minute but it's
the default there's also dispatcher to
IO which was added fairly recently and
it was designed specifically for
blocking i/o tasks so things that we
really care about you know network image
loading reading disk database blah blah
blah it uses a minimum 64 parallelism
which Bracy means it you can have up to
64 tasks run at a time which is great
for what we need so you can launch it
like that but the really great thing
about the IO dispatcher is that it
shares Fred pools with the default
dispatcher and the point where it comes
great is this so here we have an example
where we have an async
she's using the default dispatcher and
then we're gonna load an image on the
i/o dispatcher so we're gonna do some
disk reading some kind of load of image
whatever it be and then we're going to
use that result and then process it
somehow there's a computational task now
because this is running on the default
dispatcher there is no actual Fred
switch in there because we use those
assured Fred pulls IO and default uses
two shared Fred's therefore there's no
after Fred switch which makes it a whole
lot quicker then we also have dispatcher
stop main which we spoke about a little
bit already it allows running carotenes
on the UI main fred conovan who wants
with that is that in later releases
anyway ii uses service loader to load
the dispatcher in your code which is
kind of tricky when we have things like
ProGuard so you have a care for this but
yeah just be careful
the team's know is that you need to add
the Android dependency which is very
earlier anyway and then to use it as we
said just launched and then dispatch
stop me so that brings us a little bit
onto reactivity so how many blog posts
that you've seen recently anyway can be
summarized as this slide and I myself
have been guilty of this now I'm gonna
make the premise and the statement and
that most of Hugh's rxjava just because
it makes reading easy so the fact that
you have scheduled on and you can easily
switch a Fred or switch multiple threads
and that's why most iris Java is uses
and of course there are gonna be people
who go tell not top to bottom with
chains and reactivity but I think from
the AG presentment cases it's just a
switcher Fred and that's because the API
is that we have and we spoke about them
earlier aren't so great to use I'd say
that you and because of that most people
end up using things like single may be
incomplete for because that's
specifically what they are there's
single one-shot things single allows you
to always have a type maybe he's not a
ball and complete balls doesn't have a
return type so they're all pretty
similar but in fact they only actually
exist on Eric's Java are at Scala and
are it's groovy they don't actually
exist in any other platform so I said
earlier then maybe
it's more reflection of the api's that
we have our disposal rather than the
fact that they're needed Soaker Oh teens
can actually quite easily replace single
maybe incompressible they do exactly
what you think and we said earlier about
replacing callbacks they also replace
these kind of quite nicely so is an
example so we have a retrofit interface
which has a guess and it returns a
single which is just returns a list of
shows and the way you'd use that in our
xjv is you do this chaining so you'd
switch the scheduler using scheduled on
and here we can use the i/o scheduler
which is provided for you and then we're
going to do some calls to when it's
finished now the nice thing about the rx
to interrupt library of carotenes is
that you can actually use that exact
single as an await so you can actually
use it as like a suspending deferred so
it's really handy for when you're kind
of slowly migrating towards carotenes
and you don't want to change everything
know from day one you can actually keep
those interfaces all those reserve balls
and you can actually just call a weight
on them you receive inside can't be
using carotenes so it's quite a handy
way to slowly migrate but what how what
a might be great if we can actually made
that retrofit call just a suspending
function and just remove the whole rx
from the start well we can and that is
actually coming to retrofit soon jake
has a PR which is pending review and but
it's he tells me age soon so yeah it's
the crimson and then if you look at a
consuming code it's pretty much the same
it's just we can now get rid of that
weight and it's just a normal suspending
function that we've called and it you
know it's normal carotene and that
brings us on to our final section which
is kind of bringing it all back together
and trying to finger two scenarios where
we show you how to use carotenes to make
your lives easier on Android both the
examples are all about location the
first one is about actually getting the
last known location which kind of
fingers like a one shot callback so here
we're going to use the fused location
provider client which is from the Google
Play services API it's actually kind of
cool because it combines all different
providers we have like Wi-Fi and GPS and
mobile
whatever is Bluetooth provides all those
providers for you I mean to one single
API so it's actually very nice API to
use and it returns a task which is a
kind of Futura type thing that Play
services library has and yeah so you
call client get last location and they
returns a task and from the task you can
add what we call a complete listener and
then you'll get the result back
eventually so it's completely sync
so when you think about it what we're
doing is converting a callback api into
a suspending function that's pretty much
what we want to do and luckily the curie
teens library has to kind of builders
that do exactly what we want the first
is to suspend co-routine and what you do
you pass a lambda in which set which
allows you to setup your callback so I
think what we'll do here is call play
services and go get me the last location
at that point this is the Qura teen
immediately suspends waiting for the
result to come back and then the
callback can wake it back up basically
so we'll go for an example now yeah
you're given a continuation to later is
you that's how we do and analyze the
calls accountable so actually that's
different or not so there is a newer
version that's are doing which is good
luck there's another version because
suspend cancelable carotene so cousins
all add on on top and it allows you to
cancel the call so say your carotene is
canceled you can then tell the
underlying API in this case play
services to cancel its call so let's
build a function so here we can have a
suspending function called get last
location and it returns an actual
location to some intent of future or any
funada it's just a straight-up location
so we're gonna use our suspend
cancellable co-routine builder and and
then we're going to a continuation
that's a kind of callback e typing and
then we're gonna sort of set up so we're
gonna call a location client which is
the Play services API last location and
then we're gonna we get a task back and
then we're gonna add our on complete
listener at that point we are gonna wake
up actor it in so that is how we pass
back to the suspended coyote in the
result and it then wakes up and there's
a suspending function basically waits
backup resumes
now because this is a councilor ball of
a national bank really because we are
using tasks we're not using the success
isn't we using a complete listener which
means that the task itself can for an
exception like it can fail for whatever
reason so you don't have a location
permission or whatever it be now it will
raise an exception on you which means
that you can populate that back up to
the colleague which is done with the
resume with exception method and finally
because we're using suspend cancel or
co-routine we need to tell the Play
services API that we've been cancelled
so therefore each cancel so we do that
with a callback which is infocomm
completion at that point as soon as you
know that the curtain has been cancelled
which means that you need to sell five
services now they say PR doesn't
actually exist because Play Services
doesn't have a cancel method but imagine
it just exists now Adams going to talk
about observing sure so what happens
when you want to observe a sequence of
events over time no this is the thing
that our ex is really really good at
like if you're using rx for anything it
should be for this and people tend to
compare rx Java and co-routines quite a
bit in blogs and so on and so forth so
so what does it actually look like if we
try and emulate this using co-routines
as a primitive so place service is a
location API in addition to letting you
get just kind of a one shot what's my
current location
it lets you request location updates
using a callback that's invoked multiple
times so normally this is a prime
candidate to be an observable you
register a callback at subscribe time
and unregister when that subscription is
disposed we get this composable control
over shutting down the updates really
cleanly so Rx is a great library offers
a ton of functionality to build things
like this so how many similar benefits
can we get if we base this off of
suspending functions so let's again
start just writing a simple function or
at least it's going to start out simple
suspending functions don't return until
their work is all done so there's no
disposable or closable return by it
since the calling scope itself is
cancelable we just don't return until
we're done
so our observer in this case can just be
a simple lambda that accepts a location
result and we'll go ahead and call it
whenever a new locations reported
without actually returning from observed
location
so if you take in this giant pile of
code here some of you might notice that
it looks an awful lot like an observable
dot create call from our X so let's go
ahead and take it apart piece by piece
well go ahead and start off and we'll
just create this done signal that we can
await on later to know when to finish
normally and clean up so this is like
our observable completion in the case
where that you have a stream with a
well-defined end signal you can complete
this to let the observe function clean
up and return and we'll see that in a
little bit so the next piece here where
we're creating the location callback
this should really be no surprise we
need one to receive updates from the
location provider but what's interesting
here is that we use launch to call the
observer function on the same coating
dispatcher that observed location was
called on remember the co-routine scope
that we opened here carries along the
dispatcher with it that it was called
with so we always know that we're gonna
call the observer in the same place that
the call are one of the information
reported so we cancel the old job from
before and start a new one we make sure
that we call the observer while we're
holding this suspending mutex and this
keeps things serialized to make sure
that we don't have two calls to an
observer active at once we assume that
on location result won't have multiple
calls active at once either so this is
kind of an example of some of the things
that if you're building one of these
things yourself this is one of those
comparison things of like our X Java
kind of does a lot of these things for
you but with come routines we have all
the primitives to build it we just need
to do a little bit more of it by hand if
we're putting one of these things
together so we register our callback and
then we await on our done signal and
since we never complete it I mean when
does the location stream really complete
anyway this will go ahead and wait for
the calling job to be cancelled so we
remove the callback in the finally block
so it'll happen on cancellation and then
request location updates normally takes
a looper instead of something like an
executor it's just kind of unfortunate
because this pattern really shines when
you can avoid an extra hop so if you use
like a direct executor that'll just go
ahead and run the observer wherever the
update happens on the incoming binder
thread or whatever it is it really kind
of shines when you can avoid those extra
hops but you get the idea so here's what
it looks like in use and if you take a
look this looks an awful lot like just a
for each call on a collection and it
behaves exactly the same way so since we
use long
to call the observer block in the first
place if the inner block throws an
exception that means that the observed
location call itself will throw an
exception into that outer scope we can
just wrap this whole thing in a
try-catch and that's all of our error
handling that we need to do so it's a
child job so it'll cancel the parent
scope with the exception as well the
same scope that wraps the whole the
observed location function body
so it'll resume from the weight with the
cancellation exception unregistered the
location call back from the finally
block from above and all of this just
composes so you again can lean on all of
these constructs of the language that
you already know by just adding some of
these suspending primitives so let's
wrap up a little bit so what's next what
some action items for you to do well the
first is that as you saw in the keynote
earlier we actually have a code lab
specifically for co-routines and that
was released about three weeks ago which
is really good introduction it's
carotene and how to actually use it in
your app and secondly read the manual I
don't like to use do that usually but
the docs are actually really really good
the wrong kicker but you can look at
them you can even edit them if you want
to but they're all very use case based
they're all I need to do X how do I do
it so make sure to go and check it out
if you are using carotenes and that is
it thank you very much
[Music]